i feel like people get mixed up a lot
like i'm not locked in or i'm just doing
tick-tock
you know it's so different
[Music]
the thing that i think sets jared apart
is from the time he came in as a
freshman his his work ethic and there's
a lot of people that work hard but i
would say it was his attention to detail
in how he worked
i mean the drive just comes from my main
goal which is to make it to the nba i
mean that's been my goal since i was
three years old when i first started
playing basketball
so you know since i'm not there yet then
i can't really stop working
yeah you know i'm a tick tocker but i'll
still give you buckets
[Music]
peach jam is when i feel like i i blew
up the most i was uh you know combining
with the tick tocks before every game
[Music]
yeah you can't mess it up jj
i wrote down my goals for peace jam and
i achieved every single one we won peace
jam and i averaged i think 25 and five
so i was able to just do what i can do
and show out and i want mvp
i think peach shin was when i really put
everyone on notice
[Applause]
what's up jared
what up what help boy i started like
really taking basketball serious my
eighth grade year training with my
trainer every day after school and stuff
and i was able to start on varsity which
is like a blessing for me and uh so from
then on i started working every day
i would describe my game i feel like i'm
just going to make the right play every
time i'm a great shooter i can you know
if you're going to pass in the ball i'm
probably going to get that thing up and
uh most likely it's going in
the tick tock i feel like a lot of
people come at me i think it's more fun
it's like you know they're coming at you
and you're still killing them
oh
i'm just an athlete you can obviously
find a balance between having fun being
mindful of yourself and then just being
a dog on the court needs to be different
than everybody else's no matter how many
people are in there or not we bring our
own energy we do all that stuff we're
going to crank it up make sure we're
pressuring the ball from the very
beginning any questions with that i
think is basketball iq is off the charts
the screen going this way he's going
that way that's where i tagged he's
going this way is that me is that ramsey
away from you yeah that's me
and then you gotta recover back okay
if he's not the smartest player i've
ever coached he's he's up there in the
top two or three
he does a really good job of
understanding on offense how to let the
game come to him
finding open spots you know the other
teams they kind of know who he is so
defensively he gets a lot of attention
it doesn't frustrate him he stays within
it stays within the game and then you
know i talk a lot about making the right
basketball play
he makes the right basketball play the
majority of the time
i think there's a lot of players
elite players that can learn a lot by
watching him play because he plays the
right way
they won right
[Applause]
yeah before the game i'm usually just
you know there's always butterflies for
me and just nervous every game but once
you get on the course nothing everything
kind of goes away but before the game i
just get locked in i read my book that i
read before every game it's called the
inner game of tennis and you know just
puts me in the right mindset
mental side is one of the
biggest things if not the most important
thing i feel like i'm obviously not the
most athletic players
getting an edge anyway for for me was
mental so just knowing that i could stay
positive during the game and just
keeping my calm never get too high never
get too low
during the game i'm just locked into
whatever coach tells me and just locked
into winning that's really the main
thing for all this no matter how many
points you're scored ever just winning
the game
[Music]
you know jalen green has done this
a couple times so just to be in the mix
with those names so it's it's amazing to
represent california
soft is really the main word they use
for california basketball but i think
we're just
really skilled players out there
i feel like shooting is a california
thing too
my main goal for basketball i feel like
i've already started to do it a little
bit but just to inspire kids to just
keep working you know i'm not the most
athletic kid i'm not you know doing all
these crazy dunks but i just continue to
work and i continue to work and
inspiring anything whether it's
basketball or something else
you know they bought online
number 11 can come in transition
that's shannon right now playing here
yeah
that's when it's kind of going to cost
me on three one two three
for jared's future i think jared can
accomplish just about anything he wants
amen
if he were to struggle or if he has a
bad game or whatever it may be he will
turn that into a motivator and he will
become so much better because
[Music]
overall the event was good we were able
to come to south dakota and get the job
done do we had to do to win